um you you have a two-year-old at home
now
um so you're not sleeping uh but do you
put on shows for him
um we watch um first of all we listen to
a ton
of grateful dead constantly we're not
big baby shark
people in this house we're dead heads in
this house
and um he responds to it and then in
terms of tv shows he loves this show on
netflix called trash truck
and there's only like eight or ten
episodes we have watched them
so many times i need season two of trash
truck
on netflix oh my god you sound like such
a real parent now
um but have you turned into like the
full-on dad like diaper bag and all
oh my god kelly last week um sunday
night i was so excited about daylight
savings
you know and it was it was bright out at
6 00 pm so i was like
dude i'm taking you out to dinner and we
went i mean this is probably tmi but he
hadn't pooped yet for the day
and i was like i know this is gonna
happen when we go to the diner
and so i just but i didn't want to bring
his diaper bag and i also wanted to walk
so i just threw a diaper in my pocket
with some wipes
and my diaper was like his diaper was
falling out of my pocket and this
i see this super cute guy on the street
and
i'm like hey what's going on he's like
uh your diaper is falling
out of you i'm like oh great that's hot
you should have been like it's mine it's
fine right
i would have totally messed up so are
you do you think you'll have another kid
i know people always ask people that
have young kids but do you think you
will
i would like to i would like to i mean i
would like to just for
i you know i'm not looking for more to
do but uh i think for his sake it would
be great
just to have a buddy i have an older
sister and we had such a good time
growing up together we got in so much
trouble together and
i would like that for him yeah well he's
adorable oh my gosh his pictures
i just want to squeeze him yep i'm still
here just waiting for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help